well happy Thursday reject nation The
Incredibles - teaser trailer for the
Olympics dropped apparently last night
Olympic sneak peak I was out on a date
couldn't check it out then but I'm here
now David Gandy patron the day shout out
for you buddy
[Music]
superheroes are illegal
[Music]
not the doodad they want to do know that
would they change
[Music]
[Music]
oh it's so much goes on that
minute-and-a-half man
[Music]
that's so cool it picks up right where
the last one left off it's like the
ending and you're gonna see this fight
[Music]
[Laughter]
that's Bob Odenkirk voice okay it's kind
of an interesting plot turn here because
I feel like he's gonna have a similar
arc from the last one
to succeed sushi
[Music]
I mean at least it's a chance for
Elastigirl to really shine well I got
some thoughts I got some thoughts for
sure well first off I like that it
starts off immediately from where the
last Incredibles left off you don't
really see that with too many sequels
these days it picks up immediately from
the last one because the beginning of
this trailer is the continuation of this
scene from the ending of the first
Incredibles I do appreciate the role
reversal in the first one it was Bob mr.
incredible who becomes mr. incredible
first again and it's more of his
adventure as a superhero than eventually
the rest of the family Don's a super
suits in the movie it's also interesting
taking the approach of Elastigirl being
the main superhero in this one when
she's the one who seemed like she was
kind of against the whole superhero idea
but knowing this trailer I get disease
so many YouTube male comments a feminist
propaganda stuff that's not how I feel
about it I'm sure it's gonna be a really
fun time I like the approach of it while
bob is the stay-at-home parent so that's
kind of the role reversal there but then
there's also the flipside thought to
this which is it seems like it'll be a
similar arc for Bob that it was in the
first one cuz I know it wasn't so much
about how he's not good at being a
stay-at-home dad but he had just a
regular job he was broke he didn't like
his life he didn't like being a normal
person and he wanted to be a superhero
and then in this one this plot here
seems to be that again except instead of
focusing on his job necessarily it's
focused on the job of being a parent so
I kind of would have liked a more fresh
approach maybe it'll be handled
differently because in the first one he
doesn't have the storyline of Bob being
a stay-at-home dad but it is similar in
the sense of him having to do something
that normal human beings have to do all
the time and it looks like he's not
enjoying doing that as I was kind of
looking forward to a sequel where you
know the whole family is kind of a super
hero fighting team this time around I'm
sure it'll get there in the film of
course it's gonna get there in that
movie so I'm just gonna be Elastigirl
the only one who's fighting the entire
time but like I said it is cool to
switch it up where it's mainly her
adventure this time and eventually the
rest of the family will dawn the super
suits again I think it's cool to have
Bob Odenkirk this guy who wants to have
the supers be a big thing again but you
know something about the way this
trailer plays out just has me thinking
that he's a bad guy but this is just a
teaser trailer I'm sure there's a whole
lot more to come it's only a minute and
a half you don't really get a lot of
superhero action in here it's more of
this the setup for the characters and
right now I like where the setup of the
characters is at I'm sure it's gonna be
a really fun time regardless do I think
this will top the first one I have no
freaking clue anyway guys patron of the
day shout out for David Gandy David my
friend we're gonna do a google hangout
later today I just wanted to say buddy
that I love all the support you've been
giving us to the channel and I love all
the support you've been given over at
patreon you really interact with us a
lot dude I know you just got on the
Stardust app you're to put your face out
there I'm proud of you man doing
something different challenging yourself
cuz in a lot of ways you remind me of
this Bob guy you to me are a mr.
incredible you might feel like you're
older and there's some stuff that you
didn't get chances to do or whatever but
you know what dude I know you are just
this talented and a skill as you were
and even more so than when you were in
your youth we love you I love you more
than jon will ever love you just know
that anyway guys thanks for tuning in
you can subscribe to the real rejects
click that notification bell to get
notified every time one of our videos is
up and check out our patreon a lot of
exclusive perks over there having a
whole bunch of fun interacting with
everyone see you folks